No,
how about another Mejía greets you with his
brief informative for today, Thursday
, July 1, the
law school and high school is in mourning today
after the death of one of its students,
according to the forensic doctor, the 13-
year-old boy suffered a medical episode during
an athletic training Monday afternoon
the prosecution will not seek the death penalty
for 'the road' is the man accused of
killing the two-year-old minor they are sailors
in frauds he confessed to killing the minor
while the child's mother was on a
trip she  was arrested yesterday on
prostitution charges
and people making minimum wage
are about to get a raise state law
was passed in 2019 requiring a
75-cent raise each year
through 2024 hourly minimum wage for
employees with medical benefits
will now be  of 8 dollars and 75 cents for
those without medical benefits
will receive an hourly minimum wage of
9 dollars and 75 cents by the year 2024
this will go up to 12 d  ólares
the station hotel chain that if
a special anniversary is not being celebrated
and it is that 45 years ago psoe
opened the hotel and casino the station and
promoted the future of the hotel company
in las vegas'
at that time and it bore the name
of  pingo cables to celebrate
birthday the casino will have a
fireworks display
tonight with more shows planned at
the green ali and red rock hotels on the 4th
of july
and the las vigas lights soccer team and
has expanded their family this coming
saturday they will reveal  her new mascot and
although her name will be a surprise, it is
known that the new member will be a
lady who will serve as a companion for the
current team mascot tali cries out the
team is excited the revelation
will be at the end of the game against tacoma on
saturday there will also be a show
fireworks tickets are 10
dollars for adults and 5 for children
now we go to the weather conditions
with mostly clear skies  Cloudy and
low humidity today Thursday the sun will be
hotter than yesterday temperatures are expected
in the 100s
thunderstorms could be seen in the mountains
and for the rest of the
holiday weekend triple digits return to the
valley with highs in the 105s have
a  Nice day I am Héctor Mejía and this
was their brief information about them in
Spanish
[Music]